[Music]
welcome to the writing tomatoes lab
critics edition this is the third
installment in a series of virtual and
in-person panels and workshops as well
as well as editorial features that
focuses on engaging conversations and
advice for aspiring critics
breaking into the industry can be a
complex process and rotten tomatoes is
proud to collaborate with experts in the
field to provide guidance and tools for
the next generation of critics
new installments in the series are
published quarterly on
writingtomatoes.com
under the resources tab on the critics
page
i'm shirana williams producer and host
of the youtube channel para wigs our
conversation today will focus on taking
a self-published site to the next level
freelancing and growing our portfolios
we're so excited to have the following
guests here with us today
first up eric anderson is the founder
and editor-in-chief of awards watch and
a self-professed lover of all things
oscars hi eric hey sharonda hey
everybody
robert daniels is a freelance film
critic who is written for roger ever.com
the new york times vulture and polygon
he is also the founder of 812 film
reviews hi robert hey sharonda how's it
going
roxanna haddadi is a tv critic with
vulture who also writes about film and
pop culture previously she was the film
editor and critic with pajiba and her
reviews essays recaps and other writing
have also been published by the av club
polygon and roger eber.com hi roxanna
hey how are you
kristen lopez is a tv editor at indy
wire as well as a disabled critic and
sas outside of indy wire her work has
appeared in variety forbes and mtv hi
kristen
hi i'm so happy to be here
look i am happy to have all of you here
today you are some of the best in the
biz and some of the people who i just
love to stop and follow as well and
admire your work um so one of the first
questions that i wanted to start off
with is what was the moment that you
realized that you were a professional
critic
i mean for me i still don't believe i am
i i have a fair amount of of like
reminding myself like this is my job
people always ask me how did you know
you wanted to be in this career and i
was like
i just realized after 10 years of doing
it that it was uh which is which is not
the glamorous answer people tend to want
um but i think in all seriousness though
the way i knew that i was
actually having people
read my stuff and it was having an
impact was
when i started talking about
disability and
not just the rock retweeted something
that i had written about
but that people were messaging me and
being like i didn't know about
disability representation in film i
didn't know these tropes that you're
talking about
um i use certain words that i've kind of
conjured up uh when i talk about
disability stereotypes and when i hear
people use them in conversation on
twitter
it just makes me think like oh somebody
read that and more importantly somebody
took what i wrote to heart enough that
they're now watching content
and noticing whether something is
stereotypical so i think that that's for
me the moment that i knew that like oh
i'm not just writing this
to
make some money or to have fun but also
i'm hopefully influencing people to be
more aware
of what they're watching and why stories
are being told in the way that they are
i think
a cynical answer would be
when you get paid for it then it sort of
becomes real it sort of feels real
but
it not necessarily it's it's only like a
half cynical way you do sometimes almost
stumble into this
you may want to do it and you're kind of
stretching your legs on how to do it
and
then you're kind of suddenly in it and
like kristin said you're
something that
you're enjoying
becomes something bigger than
sort of yourself in the moment and i
think that's kind of it when you have
interactions and when you have
uh
conversations that are
based off something you said or wrote
then it becomes something bigger than
than yourself and i think that's kind of
a moment
these are all very uh thoughtful answers
and considerate answers i think my
answer was just when i was in college i
started out as a features writer for my
college newspaper the dimebag of the
university of maryland uh in my freshman
year and then sophomore year i became
editor of the entertainment section and
so that brought with it you know writing
about movies and being invited to movie
screenings and sort of realizing that
there was
a system set up for this sort of writing
and this sort of commentary and
different tiers of access um so i think
that first entry into that world and
sort of figuring out how to navigate
that that was when i realized
okay so like this is how you do this
profession and this is how you start
from point a and move to point b
um and then of course there's all the
other stuff that comes with it right
like people recognizing your work or
asking you about your work or sharing it
on twitter or all these different
mechanisms that we have but i think the
first one for me was just getting
involved in my college paper and going
from there
yeah i think roxanna you brought up uh
screenings and
the first
film screening i went to as a critic um
it was um
for ethan hawk's blaze and
and ethan hawk was there to do like a
post q a with the critics which is like
a rarity in chicago
i didn't know i didn't know i was being
spoiled you know but when i sat down and
i saw all of these people who i read
over the years and knowing that i was
sitting with them and i was about to
write about the same movie that was kind
of when it clicked i mean a lot of times
outside of just wanting to become a
professional credit a lot of people
really stumble across like how do i
actually get to watch movies before they
actually hit theaters and i want to know
like what is that experience been like
actually being able to get on the press
list to attend screenings um for having
a self-published site but also to as a
freelancer what does that process look
like for you
there's there's levels so it's different
if you live in a major city and it's
different if if you don't live in a
major city it's also different if you
are working for a self-publishing site
versus if you were just a freelancer or
working for anything that is established
so with regards to location in my
experience
when i was starting out i lived in
sacramento which is not new york or la
which
pre-pandemic meant that you had it was
relatively
i would say easier because you had one
company that you had to get in their
good graces um and so i could not do
that on my own it was not until that i
was brought on to a site that had
relatively high traffic that person
emailed the rep for the the company that
ran most of the screenings in sacramento
and they got me in and once i left that
site they never updated their their
stuff so it was just it worked out that
i was able to get in from there when i
moved to los angeles it was all it was
completely different because there is no
unified central company that handles
all the screenings you're dealing with
individual studios and individual reps
within those studios that may be
handling certain movies so
i had to rely a lot on twitter at that
point asking fellow critics hey do you
know who's handling this movie um you go
into facebook groups of
critics organizations that i was a part
of um and then from there it became what
is your outlet you know because in my
experience once i got here
it was often
depending on what
i was doing you know so i could email a
rep and be like hey
i don't have an assignment but i'm
trying to think about this for future
consideration as a freelancer so i need
to be able to see it and that most of
the time would get me in
um depending on if it was for a trade
and i needed to see a really early like
long leads you know i kind of had to use
the outlet um but most of the time and i
can still do this now you know is kind
of be like hey i'm looking at this for
consideration or i'm a member of a
critics organization that votes and you
know i'd like to be sure that i can see
this so there's a bit more flexibility
if you live in a big city to be like
just because i don't have a piece or i'm
not at a big outlet you know you're not
automatically xed out
um whereas if you live in a smaller city
you know you're usually working at the
mercy of one company that's going to
determine how important your outlet is
i mean eric for you
how does does this differ with the
process since you cover awards do you
tend to go to screenings your year-round
or is it just more more so during oscar
season or award season that you actually
start attending screenings
well um i'm in the san francisco bay
area so uh the group that kristen was
talking about when she was in sacramento
is the same group that i deal with up
here uh which is pretty much nationwide
if you aren't new york and la
um
so that that was my beginning that's all
of my my press screenings and that just
is the normal
press ratings that everybody else gets
and
award screenings become a little
a little different the access is a
little different it's a little quicker
um
but
yeah
kristen was really was really
right you're
if you are not in a major city it's
extremely difficult i imagine for
anybody that is you know watching or
listening to this and they live in
you know the midwest or you know
whatever nebraska or something and
they're like how in the world do i
possibly you know break into something
like this because we don't all live
on the coast or in in a city
even if we eventually get there
and i i think
i think it's very difficult but
uh
if you have
if you have passion and ambition
i would always recommend reaching out to
a mutual or a contact
in order to help
kick-start that i have several writers
that
live
across the country uh and would never
have the access
that a san francisco los angeles or new
york person would have ever
so they're really
dependent on that and and i think if we
have the ability to give
that access for it's it's a great thing
to do we're we're helping
create the new generation of
writers and critics and
people with voices
and also to just my own personal
experience before i was actually on a
prep list i would just go stand in line
three to four hours i know this is not
as glamorous as it may seem but i would
there's advanced screening so there's
free screenings available to the public
before movies come out not for every
single title but depending on what area
you live in there are screenings that
are happening and you can just you get
tickets do contest giveaways i will go
to radio websites or go to other
bigger sites who are doing ticket
giveaways and i would just stand in line
with my food in a chair and just wait
and pray that i can actually make it
into the stream
so
you can make a way out of no way without
yeah and if you if you do that and you
see something ahead of the majority of
the general public and you
whatever if it's a a blog or a sub stack
or whatever it is that you have if you
get you know some words out before
general public does people will take
notice people will see that i will say
also that this has been very film
focused that we've talked about uh i
mean tv also gives you screeners that is
a manner of
googling pretty much every streamer
every network has a press website for
which you can register and you can find
press contacts and you can reach out to
those for screeners of tv shows often
netflix also will give screeners of
movies i think absolutely there has been
post covid although we're still in covet
i refer to it as post the great
expansion there has been more of a
crackdown on like the hierarchical
nature of if you're not in new york or
la it's going to be more difficult for
you to get access to movies but i will
say that i think if you are interested
in tv criticism i think that there is
some more flexibility there in terms of
gaining access so that's also something
to consider is that google is your
friend let me piggyback off of that
because especially when you cover tv
there's a lot more reaching out that you
have to do just given how many studio
streamers that we have at this point um
can you talk a little bit about the
process like how do you actually pitch
the studios how do you pitch these pr
agencies what does that process look
like
i mean i think it depends as we've all
discussed on who you're writing for
uh if you're writing for a specific
outlet with certain name recognition as
a freelancer something that i would
often need to do is email the publicist
and say hello i'm roxanne hidatti i'm
reaching out on behalf of vulture i'll
be writing recaps for this series my
editors cc here so they can confirm my
assignment can you please provide me
with access
um and that's generally you know the
template again it's just a lot of
googling to try to find people
um so that's when you have the
assignment um when you're attempting to
get the assignment again it's a matter
of like
which outlets do you read the most
what is their voice do you want to write
for them and what would you offer and i
think that's a matter of
for as many flaws as twitter has
you can find editors and their contact
information and people looking for
pitches and i think that's a matter of
pitching yourself to those outlets
and sort of just
figuring out a way to describe your
style what you would bring to an
assignment and send it and keep your
fingers crossed and hope for the best it
is a lot
of chasing down contacts and knowing
what you offer to that assignment but i
mean i will say like robert was somebody
that i read for ebert
and i you know i thought like it would
be so cool to write for ebert you know
and then
with time and with work that could
happen but i think it's a matter of
being aware of who you want to write for
what their voice is what you would bring
to it
and then the pipeline of
hunting down what you need to do to be
able to do that there are a lot of steps
involved i can't lie about that with
regards to pitching um
i you know like twitter is of course a
fantastic place to pitch you know i've
gotten
the amount of dm's i've gotten from an
editor who's you know i saw your tweet
can you write about this you know give
you 800 words about this and
um that's pretty common but you know um
i think what's also really good about
twitter is that not only you know
what i would say is that
i wouldn't like
code email an editor too often like i
think twitter's really good about
building connections and building
organic connections things that don't
feel like transactional um and i think
sometimes you know which one of course
you can become closer with editors and
then editor starts looking out for your
work they start reading you and then at
some point maybe they have an assignment
and they reach out right so sometimes
you can do that with you can get
assignment without even pitching just
being yourself and not trying to get you
know get something out of it
um and then you know with pitching in
general
you know if you want to reach out to an
editor
um
typically when i pitch i try to the
pitch to be the short as short as
possible
you know like very quick
uh include like possible headline
very quick synopsis of like maybe two or
three sentences of what i'm thinking
where the piece is gonna go what i
already have like research wise it and
then
get right out of there you know um and
that you know that's worked pretty well
um so i guess
most of mostly what i'm you know kind of
getting around is there's no quick way
as roxanna said right there's a lot of
steps involved
and that whether it's
becoming close with editors or whether
it's becoming close to publicist um
but you know when you get there
it tends to get easier to get access but
you know as we all know it
also depends on where you're where
you're located at and
what the studio is some studios are much
more open to giving away stuff like say
netflix is kind of open you know whereas
a few other bigger studios or not
but um but yeah but just in general i
think really just put yourself out there
and just
you know keep writing get to as many
early screenings as you can and just
keep writing and you know typically
someone will take notice at some point
some of the things that i even did is i
would like go and look up press releases
for movies press releases for tv shows
go search like the studio website
sometimes they have contacts and they
actually spell out for this tv show or
for this movie you can contact this um
this person like when roxanna said
google is your friend the types of
things that i would do to try to google
and find people and guess email
addresses depending on what the company
email address is like that is so so
helpful um but i think also too
networking is a huge like piece to that
um especially going to film festivals
going to tv festivals actually being
able to put a face to the name sometimes
like cold emailing does not help because
they're getting hundreds of emails from
everyone across the country in the
entire world trying to get access to
some of these titles and actually being
able to put a face to the name and
meeting someone in person like that's
how i've actually been able to get on
like press sites get access to media
sites um so i think networking even
being able to reach out to people in dms
and be like hey can you look over this
like pitch email that i have for
interviews or to get access to tv shows
it's like little things like that that
just make the world of difference
actually let me ask all of you because
networking is something that people
don't talk about but it's a huge piece
and i wanted to know for all of you
like when did you realize that
networking is just as important as
pitching to the studios and pitching to
these publicists
day one
[Laughter]
um
i don't think there's anything more
important than
than networking and robert mentioned
that these relationships can sometimes
feel transactional and sometimes they
they are
uh if it's often
the publicist writer
relationship can feel very transactional
um
not that that's necessarily a bad thing
you're both
in business to accomplish something
it doesn't have to be you know
a really reality show where you're i'm
not here to make friends but
it doesn't hurt either um it's
it's really helpful when
you respond to a publicist or when you
reach out to a public and you do it in a
way that is
is like a two-way street rather than
simply here's what i need from you
because
you know i think we can
we can bag on
publicist as we do sometimes
but at the same time
they have
a crazy difficult job
uh and
and i i think the more that we can
humanize each other in those
conversations and relationships the
better and that
that is the better part of networking
for me
um like you said toronto going to film
festivals and stuff like that is my
bread and butter
for meet and greets
because everything else for me is email
or phone
so those are those are crucial for me i
love those and i love networking anyway
i love
talking with people and i will go up to
anybody you know that sharonda i will go
up to anybody
anytime i don't have any any issues with
that at all
so that's always that that that's great
for me not everybody
can can do that
so then emails
become a very comfortable form of
conversation
yeah i mean i hesitate i don't know i
i have a very
complicated relationship with networking
and that i think that
having a large network is i think of
course important because we're writing
about so many different kinds of content
and stuff like that but there's also
part of me that thinks that
ultimately
we are also offering criticism as
service in the same way that publicists
are offering access
so i i hesitate to say that a
transactional relationship is
necessarily bad you're both serving a
function and you're both doing a job
um i've been doing this for 13 years
i've only ever attended two film
festivals you know so i think that they
are important but i also don't
necessarily think they're the end-all
be-all i think that
your portfolio and your body of work can
exist without film festivals which
honestly can be very expensive for
freelancers and i know of freelancers
who go to film festivals and don't get
assignments out of that so i think that
something that is more
perhaps attainable is sort of that sense
of if you're writing for yourself if
you're maintaining your own website
you're writing on whatever you're
amassing a body of work that as robert
mentioned you're linking to in these
emails to prove what your voice is and
what you can offer
and sometimes that can result in a film
festival application and sometimes it
doesn't but i think there are a lot of
different ways to go about this because
a lot of people are
all around the country and we're all
offering different things so i just
think something to consider is like
what drives you and what you're
passionate about and what you want to
write about and finding ways
to do that that might not necessarily
equal you spending money to do that i'm
just sort of hesitant to say
that you need to
you know put money out to sort of gain
attention for your work i'm just a
little hesitant to say that
there's also you know if part of this is
also to entice disabled critics to get
into this industry there's still a lot
of rampant ableism when it comes to
networking you know i
despite my job title you know i've still
gone to events where
because nobody's ever seen a disabled
person you know working at a trade
they just assume that you know i'm i'm a
guest that you know maybe is like a
friend of somebody you know they don't
know that i am a tv editor you know and
it's the logistics of kind of going into
a space whether that's a premiere or a
film festival you know it's not it's not
as easy for me to be able to walk up to
somebody who maybe is not paying
attention and is incredibly tall you
know and then having this conversation
in a very crowded room so networking i
always kind of
tried to pivot in a certain way you know
i'm very open with like zoom you know
again if there's a silver lining to the
pandemic being like hey you know like
let's you know if you want to have kind
of like a meet and greet and kind of
figure out how we can work together like
let's have a zoom talk let's have a
coffee somewhere you know and try to you
know if the goal is to kind of press
flash so to speak you know taking out of
those spaces where i do often feel very
marginalized and uncomfortable just
because of the logistics of being a
disabled critic and kind of taking it
into a place where i feel comfortable so
i think that it requires
for especially marginalized critics
to kind of really kind of set boundaries
about what you want to get out of
networking and make it
i don't want to say advantageous to you
because that sounds very venal but but
make it so that you do feel comfortable
so it's not just about like
trying to amass a network of people as
quickly as possible but really foster
you know contacts that you know are
going to
understand where you're coming from we
gotta talk about finances
and how freelancing having your own site
doesn't pay the bills is it the only
thing that you can do let's let's talk
about how
i guess the first question is as
freelancers how do you do you have a
rate that you kind of stay at like hey
if there's anything below this i'm just
not going to do it like when did you
start learning that financially i have
to like
stand true
to like what i want to charge to
contribute to websites
it was a process for me when i was
starting out because
you know as women were told not to uh
not to be difficult and often you know
just kind of take what we're handed and
be thankful anybody wants to pay us at
all um and so i worked for
a marginal amount of money
for a very long time i won't say how
much it was but uh it was about the
price of a movie ticket before 3d became
a thing um and i did that for for a long
time uh and it wasn't until
i i realized i had to find a way to
sustain myself and like make this a
thing if i was going to do it that i
started being like you know
getting higher amounts of money um but
even then it was
you know not a lot of money um you know
50 to 75 tended to be kind of the
starting rate depending on what you were
doing
um and it wasn't until i started working
with trades or at least bigger sites
like a vulture like a box
where you could get triple digits
depending on how much work you were
doing um
and and so i especially when i was
freelancing full-time would often have
kind of like a spreadsheet that would be
laid out you know in terms of like okay
these are people that don't pay a lot
but they'll take whatever i can you know
produce um these are people that pay a
lot of money but it's gonna take me a
lot of time in order to do it um so it
would be a process of kind of like
picking from each column being like okay
this is where i'm gonna pitch this
depending on how much time it took so if
it was like
you know kind of like a piddly little
essay that i could do in you know 6 to
800 words i'm like okay i can take a
little bit less for it because i'm not
interviewing anybody if it was something
that required extensive research and i
was going to have to interview people i
was like well i'm certainly not going to
send it to the place that's only gonna
pay me 50 bucks i'm going to try to
shoot it to the person that's going to
pay me you know 200 maybe um
you know and even then you know i think
the biggest myth that i'm hoping is
being dispelled you know in the
world right now is the concept of
raises in the freelance world you know a
lot of people said oh well if you're
producing good work you can ask to
renegotiate the rate
in my experience that was never an
option you know they were like well this
is the rate that the site has decided
that we can pay you if the site makes
more money then maybe we can raise the
freelancer pool
you know everybody would be profiting it
wouldn't just be i never got an increase
in my rate because of who i was or how
much i was contributing or what i was
writing so
so yeah it was definitely a process of
like
looking at my bills every month being
like what's the dollar amount i need to
hit and then breaking that down into who
i was going to reach out to and you know
kind of ask them like hey what are you
looking for so that i could start kind
of building the freelance uh budget that
i would need in order to sustain myself
i mean roxanna you talked about working
another job on top of freelancing it's
like can you shed a little more light
about that
uh sure uh when i graduated from college
09 it was like the worst time to
graduate with a journalism degree
[Laughter]
bleak it was bleak um so i worked as a
copy editor for a couple of years at the
washington post company i went back to
grad school i got a degree in
american literature and film i got a
master's degree uh and then again there
weren't a lot of full-time criticism
jobs when i graduated in 2013. um so i
took a job doing uh like fundraising and
development writing
and i did that for eight and a half
years at a state university
um and so it was it was still writing
and i actually
treasure that job a lot because it
taught me a lot about writing on
deadline interviewing it continued
things i'd studied in journals and
school in a different context
but yes
for those
13 years across a variety of jobs i had
a full-time job and then also freelanced
on top of that
it is exhausting and grueling
but i you know i appreciated that i had
the security of sort of an unrelated job
outside of criticism uh i you know i
don't
i hate to advise that to people but at
the same time it sort of allowed me to
further develop my voice because i was
freelancing and pitching things that i
was really passionate about um and i
sort of had the flexibility to say okay
like maybe i don't want to write
anything this month maybe i just want to
take a break from writing and i hate
that that is the advice that i have to
give but truly
i would give that advice like if there
is the possibility for you
to have a day job that is sort of
unrelated but gives you some security
and some flexibility to figure out who
you want to be as a writer and what you
want to write
i would encourage that truly it has been
after 13 years of freelancing that i got
a staff job so i just i again i hate to
be harsh in that way but in some ways i
think we have to be realistic about what
this industry is and perhaps what the
limitations of upward mobility within it
are
um so yeah so in that time that i was
freelancing you know like i was pitching
places constantly i was forming those
relationships i was moving up from
the small local publications to the
larger local publications to the
national publications there is that
pipeline right um but it it it took time
and i just think that that is
a reality that it takes time how do you
establish
what your freelance rate is is it
something that should contingent on what
the outlet offers you or do you have a
amount that you stick to like hey this
is what i need to pay well you know i
think
when you're first i mean when you're
first starting out you're writing
wherever you can and that's just it
right sometimes you're writing for free
which
you know sucks but like that sometimes
it's just like if you're just trying to
get the byline
cool i'll do it and i'll do the couple
of assignments and you know move on to
the next thing and like kristen was
saying like you get to about
kind of start moving up moving up um
to
um
you know say like 50 to 75 then maybe 75
to 100 and then maybe you start going
over that 100 250 you know
but for me
um
it's hard to say you know how do you
establish your rate because so many of
the rates are
they're set in stone by the outlet you
know there's just
certain outlets they only pay 100 and
that's it
not gonna give right so
you can choose
not to take those right um which
um
would you would have to be in a very
privileged position not to take those
or you you know you do what kristen said
right where you have like you know maybe
a spreadsheet or maybe even
unconsciously like i can afford to take
two assignments from this this place two
assignments from this place three from
this place and if i can get one from
this place
it'll help out with everything else
right
um for me so you know you know you know
and you can give sometimes on your rate
you know like um there was uh there's a
movie that checked to come out that i
you know gave on my rate because i
really wanted to cover it and i couldn't
find
an outlet to cover it for but i really
really wanted to write about it um and
so sometimes you know you can lower your
rate if it's a passion project right but
in terms of establishing a rate i think
you establish your rate
you know
based on basically you know
what what outlets you're writing for
right there's a once you start writing
for a quarter a class of outlets your
rate is basically there and it rarely
drops below unless you consciously let
or want to drop below that um so really
in terms of rate it's about once again
getting to that level of a byline where
you know for sure that's the that's the
minimum you're going to get paid
i think you establish a cutoff rather
than a rate
because i have never had an opportunity
where i'll say like i'm going to write
this for you and give me 500 right like
that doesn't happen
that's not how this industry works
although i would love to walk up to
people and tell them to give me 500
that's just not how it is right so i
think something that's more particular
is what is your cut off what are you not
willing to do again i will say uh just
quickly because i know eric wants to
jump in on this too again in terms of
television
if you are covering television recap
game is still strong out here people are
still paying for individual recaps there
are publications that will pay you 200
for a recap so if you are interested in
not just writing about film criticism
but also writing about tv again it is a
matter of like
knowing your knowledge in that area
pitching recaps what can you bring to
them all of that stuff and robert and i
have talked about this often sometimes
that can be a burden because then you're
writing about 10 episodes of a tv show
that might not always be the best if the
tv show is inconsistent but if it is
something that you really enjoy if you
like the show if you enjoy the process
of diving deep into essays then the
recap space might be also something that
is
a you know
a cement
job right it's like if you can book
recaps for a season of tv that's
something consistent over a month two
months so that's also something to
consider eric i'm sorry what were you
gonna say no that was a great point i
like that you brought up recaps and keep
bringing television back into the
conversation because it is a totally
different animal than film and the
process is just very different the
people are different and
it's yeah so i'm just really glad that
you're that you keep bringing that up um
i mean obviously i'm on the opposite
side i guess of this
where i'm not a freelancer so i don't
have a rate i do i do the opposite i
have to create my budget
for writers when i am terrible at doing
that because i want to say yes to
everybody for everything and then i you
know look at my numbers at the end of
the month and i'm like oops
[Laughter]
oopsie daisy awesome so then i have to
be a little more judicious with
what can i take on what do i want to
take on because i want to dig everything
on but you know you can't you can't
always do that and it's it's just sort
of the other side of the coin to be of
having to balance what is your reality
for doing what you're doing
um i i have to say no
when i want to say yes
several times a month and
it breaks my heart it sucks because you
know i want to work with everybody
but i can't all the time
so eric you're saying we should all
pitch you
you i
love being pitched i am
kind of a pushover but
yeah but in terms of talking with people
about their rates though
um i'm
really open
and flexible and i think reducing stigma
of conversations about money
has to continue and keep happening i
love when i see like full-on threads on
twitter not about freelancers but other
like you know groups and companies and
organizations and people be like i made
this much money at this company and
i think it's really important because
knowing your own personal value is a
huge important part about
emotional integrity and stamina in doing
this job it is not it is not easy like
you know roxanna said it's not just you
know hey i get to see the movie first
you really need to want to do this and
love doing it not just be good at it you
need to have all of the things you need
to really really really want it but you
have to know to what you will
compromise where you'll compromise and
when
and not keep doing that to hopefully
kind of get something and and beat your
your
emotional well-being up in the process
how do you make sure that you're not
being pigeon-holed into only talking
about certain aspects of film or
television i.e from your race your
gender sexual background you know how do
you make sure that you're not being
pigeonholed and then what are some of
those times where you're like okay this
is a topic that i actually have to be
the person to speak on how you
differentiate between that
for me at least and it's something i
still
work with now
you know
i definitely
it took me a long time to want to write
about disability you know it was just
never something that i thought anybody
was interested in and when i started to
write about it
i was like i i don't want to just write
about this because
you know
it often limits a lot of
good opinions you'd have about content
that maybe isn't talking about
specific marginalized issues but really
is you know i always say like disney
movies are all disabled stories if you
really look at them but you know if i'm
only writing about the few disabled
movies that come out then you miss all
of these other opportunities where i
could be talking about something
different so so when i got the the job i
have now you know that was a big thing
that i disclosed up front was that you
know i really do want to talk about
marginalized issues but at the same time
i don't want to just talk about those
things um and so for me you know at
least with what i look at now
you know i do
have the privilege of being a bit more
selective when you know a disability
pitch comes down the pipe you know where
somebody will be like hey
we have this show that's coming out and
it's got you know a disabled person in
it wouldn't you love to write about it
and i usually i now am in the position
where i'm like look
is it about a disabled white guy you
know who's like
you know in a wheelchair i've i've
reviewed that a million times you know i
need at this point us to be furthering
those conversations you know come at me
when it's about uh a woman of color
who's disabled or there's a disabled
showrunner or there's a disabled you
know something else like i at this point
am now in this unique privileged
position where i can say like
i really want to be talking about
disability in a way that is promoting
shows that are trying to do the work you
know and not just
celebrating every show because it gains
to have
some person sit down in a wheelchair and
tell a disabled plotline um you know i i
can kind of pick and choose at the same
time you know when i there is a show
that comes out you know and i watch it
and it is something where i'm like
all the other people at all the other
websites are gonna say how great and
progressive the show is and it's really
not you know so i do often feel like i
have a responsibility at that point even
if it's something that i don't
necessarily
want to talk about where i'm like
there's not enough of us at this point
in in you know key positions that
i have to be able to talk about
something where if it if it is
something that is positive or something
that's negative like i'm like i have to
talk about it because
i'm in this position that i that i'm in
so i do think that
you know i as somebody who doesn't want
to be pigeonholed
i do feel that there is a responsibility
at times you know that i i'm like okay
well until there's you know 18 other
disabled critics that are in the same
position as me like right now i kind of
have to leave the charge
so like where we should be celebrating
where we should be saying like uh it's
not that great so it's it's a lot more
where i have to kind of create those
boundaries again and say like
maybe i don't have to cover this thing
but i do know that i need to be fighting
to talk about this thing
yeah that's a
he's a sports analogy but you kind of
have to create your own opportunities
and then when i you know say that in
terms of like say like
uh writing
about something i think we've so far
really talked about recaps and reviews
but you know there are think pieces you
can write there you can do interviews
like there are different ways i think
you can show you know different facets
of like you know if
i know sometimes that happens where i'll
get like a run of um
uh either black shows or black films and
i'm like i really want to kind of try to
break out and i'm like well all right
let's start pitching something let's
think of something that you know
something else to write about and pitch
maybe an editor that i know will take it
you know or oh this movie's coming out
um i really want to interview that
person i think i can maybe if i ask this
editor maybe i can get that set up um
and so i think there are different ways
to
approach
uh a tv show or film in ways where
you can maybe
you know hit a different beat or you can
hit your usual beat and hit a different
one at the same time kill two birds with
one stone so i think
um there always be kind of like aware of
the different opportunities that you
have
to try something different and to write
about something different and to kind of
show
you know a new a new side to you so to
speak you know to other editors
[Music]
uh i mean i think it's a matter of like
thinking broadly again about what you
care about i mean all of us yes come
from
underrepresented communities in some way
or another
um but we also all have other things
that we're passionate about writing
right like i would love to write about
michael mann movies like i want to write
about absurdist comedies so i think it's
a matter again of like
if you can develop a portfolio
that
reflects your other interests and then
it's not just a matter of like oh like
there are terrorists in the show like
let's ask roxanna if she can yell about
the terrorists in this show you know
what i mean it's like you you want to be
known for like a greater totality of
things that you're passionate about and
that can only come through your writing
so i echo what robert said i mean if
you're sending pitches if you're sending
like a half dozen pitches then it's a
matter of just like reflecting your own
interests in those on the flip side of
this and this speaks to what kristen
said is like sometimes you know you're
one of the few people in that space so
like do you want to take on that
responsibility and that burden of being
the lone voice who says like actually
this thing that you love sucks
like there's also the danger of that on
twitter if you get known as the person
who hates everything involving a certain
group or whatever so these are all just
like individual choices that you have to
make on your own sometimes they vary
sometimes you contradict yourself
all those things are allowed they're
just being a person and being a writer
so i would just say like when you're
pitching when you're covering things
like you everybody cares about more than
one thing right so just try to explore
those other things that you care about
so that somebody can know
kristin likes x and y robert cares about
a and c
eric loves m
and p i'm running out of letters here
but like i think you know what i mean
right it's like you don't if you don't
want to be just the person for this one
thing
show that through your writing last
thing i'll just say about that too is
like as a person of an underrepresented
group like know your limitations like i
can't speak to the entire experience of
people from the middle east and it's
unfair of an editor to ask me to do that
so i think it's also just a matter of
like it might suck to say no to an
assignment but it might serve you better
sometimes to say no to an assignment it
might put the kibosh on some story ideas
that shouldn't progress so again i think
it's just like there is like a two-way
responsibility when it comes to some of
these story ideas and it might you know
be beneficial to like push back on an
idea of like i actually didn't get that
message from this piece and i wouldn't
necessarily want to be
you know i wouldn't want my bylight on
it i don't know if you can say that but
i do think again in terms of like
networking connections there is some
like finessing that can happen so that
you're writing a piece that like you're
proud of and sometimes it might not work
out but sometimes it does so i think
it's just a matter also of like knowing
what you're comfortable doing and
advocating for yourself in that way as
well i want to know what is some of the
best advice that you've been given as a
critic and what are some lessons learned
if you knew then what you know now what
advice would you give to yourself
quarterly taxes
[Laughter]
yeah that was really loud thanks
what i will say though i think the best
advice i got was actually before i
became a critic when i was in grad
school um i was in
this uh dystopian uh
literature short story class i was
writing dystopian literature it sounds
just like me i guess but um
the professor was like she was a writer
and she had a couple bestsellers
and
we like talked to her about like
well how did you like make it and she
was like i was probably the second worst
writer in my class these are the best
writers i'll quit you know like
and it's true like you know this as as
we've been talking about this is it's
group this is grueling right it's
it's hard you have to really really
really want to do it and there's nothing
wrong with quitting right if you're at
the point where you're burned out and
you're afraid and you are i should say
afraid
um
then definitely take a step back but
what i'd also say is that like you know
sometimes you also have to push through
and
you know a lot of the really really
really great writers end up quitting and
you know the
people who don't do quote unquote make
it tend to be the people who just kind
of stuck with it
i'd say for me you know it's not
necessarily advice i was given but you
know kind of
just learning through hard
and bad situations is
never
especially if you are a woman you know
or or from a marginalized group like the
disabled community that is still kind of
considered niche
um you know never
never be open to being like the token um
you know never believe somebody an
editor or a fellow colleague that says
like oh
you know we need your voice because we
think that you know always always
question why what about you they they
want
you know i i think one of the the
moments i always go back to is an editor
that asked me to be part of their
website um when i was freelancing where
they were like
you know i just need you to be
like the disabled and culture for our
our site and i was you know like what
you know what did they what so i always
say question what an editor sees in your
work never be afraid to ask an editor
like why are you coming to me why do you
think that i'm good because
sometimes you know
some peop some some sites just want kind
of hate clicks and the problem is is
that their name isn't on you know the
piece it's yours and and i always say
like
write something that you
would be proud of you know like even if
i've written you know i've written some
stories that i look back on like yeah
probably didn't bet on the right horse
there um but at the same time i was like
at the time i really felt confident that
i was writing something that was really
good um you know always be writing for
yourself
and not for
a site you know for an editor who maybe
you know doesn't always have the best
intentions so
that's the advice i i wish i had known
at the time that i i kind of take with
me now
um the thing that i would say and this
is maybe like too existential but i
think all of you guys know that
unfortunately that is one of my flaws
um is like do other things
you know like
movies and tv and all this stuff is
great we love pop culture that's why we
do these things right but like
you will only become a better writer a
better critic a better thinker
if you do other things consume other
types of media like
read
sorry that's so blood but like read
right like read other things have other
interests i think that that is really
important
in terms of expanding your world view
people are reading you because they're
interested in your world view they want
to know what kristin has to say and what
eric has to say and what robert has to
say like they want your specific voice
and i think what you need to do is
incorporate other things about the world
in which we live in to further
understand what you care about and what
you're looking for in the art that
people are reading your opinions on
so i think my my advice is just like
think
about more than just the thing in front
of you and try to
you know
corny advice do something new every so
often i i you know i just think that
like to be a good writer you have to
know like what you care about and i just
think that the only way to do that is to
like experience more read more watch
more do things that are not just
this
i think one of the earlier pieces is
pieces of advice that i was given was
say yes to everything which was at the
time great advice until it's not you
know you you do hit a point where you
know that it's not but i'll absolutely
echo roxanna that have experiences and
interests outside of what you're doing
because it will only inform
your writing even more in in such a
bigger broader way
at telluride a couple of years ago renee
zellweger said that one of the reasons
that she had like taken a big break from
acting was that she wasn't she was just
working
and she wasn't
experienced experiencing anything
to then bring into like her roles and i
thought that was really fascinating the
the way that we that we kind of do that
whether it's an actor or whether it's us
that infuse ourselves in our writing as
well
it comes from our personal experience
and if we are so locked into just this
then we're not having any we're in our
own bubble
and and we don't get to experience other
people other lives other
foods other and you know we just
we have to spread ourselves out a little
bit i think that was fantastic advice
for example
i just want to thank all of you for
being panelists today and sharing some
words of wisdom and telling me that i
need to read more thank you roxanna
i bought some books on amazon i'm
actually going to read them because of
you
but i just want to thank everyone out
there who is watching and listening i
hope that you learned some great gems
just as i have listening to the group of
panelists today
and i also want to let you know that you
can visit rottentomatoes.com
backslash critics to find other
resources and other installments of the
rt lab editions i hope that everyone has
a great day thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you